now know that there are at least seven
victims possibly eight and that the
school shooting happened at a middle at
the middle school section of this stem
school in Highlands Ranch Colorado for
those of you who weren't with us earlier
about 150 local time Mountain time in
Denver a reports of shots fired at stem
school in Highlands Ranch that south of
Denver passed Littleton Colorado where
Columbine High School is and then the
next community is Highlands Ranch the
Sheriff's Department just gave us an
update they originally said two victims
now we know there were seven and
possibly eight it happened in a middle
school section of this school it's a K
through 12 place but it was in the
middle school building two juvenile
suspects are now in custody
the sheriff says they're both juveniles
they don't know if there were students
at that school but two are in custody
the sheriff had reported that they were
looking for a possible third suspect
they no longer believed there was a
third suspect the school administrators
reported shots fired officers arrived
within minutes they put they're still
going door-to-door at the school so it's
somewhat of an active scene but they
believe at least that the danger to
students has passed again an active
scene Highlands Ranch Colorado but two
suspects are in custody